[Applause]
and finally new rule you can't call it a
drought if it happens all the time
in a story i'm getting tired of
reporting california is running out of
water
and this time just when we started
showering again
19 000 acres of forest have already
burned this year and 72 percent of the
entire west is in severe drought
turns out hot girl summer is for reals
the bay area was just placed under a
water shortage emergency
with mandatory restrictions except
here's the thing
there isn't even with the drought really
a water shortage problem it's more a
where the water is going problem
california agriculture accounts for 80
percent
of our water use even though california
agriculture
is less than two percent of our economy
we actually have enough water we just
give way too much of it to farmers
who get their water subsidized by the
government because we still act like
it's 1890
and farmers are small and independent
when they're really mostly part of big
ag
old macdonald is now e-i-e-i-o
incorporated
and corporations get what they want in
america we have spent the last two
decades in perpetual drought here yet
almond farmers
in california have doubled in that time
despite the fact that almond production
alone uses more water than all the
humans
and businesses in san francisco and los
angeles combined
even on days when your teenage son
spends two hours
showering
but
look at this chart of how much water it
takes to grow different crops
oranges tomatoes strawberries all take
about 11 gallons to make
one pound almonds 1900 gallons
that wasn't a problem back when it
rained but now there simply isn't enough
water to go around
and we have to make a painful choice
getting it to the people or getting it
in the nuts
and listen i i i don't have some
personal vendetta against almonds
they're just not more important than the
entire ecosystem of california
so when i hear that our state grows 81
of the whole world's almonds the world's
thirstiest crop
while our reservoirs run dry and giant
fires burn out of control
i have a few questions starting with
what the [ __ ]
this is
this is life and death and almonds are
just not crucial
no one has a t-shirt that says don't
talk to me until i had my almonds
they're fine in salads or in a gift
basket for someone you don't really care
about
and an almond joy is nice to have but
it's really just a mounds bar with tits
there will still be almonds in the world
even if they're not grown in places that
never get rain
if we can direct coal miners in west
virginia to another line of work because
coal is killing us
we should be able to tell almond farmers
you can't grow almonds where they don't
grow anymore
you're bogarting the water
and
because you know it's not like
california doesn't know how to regulate
oh
oh they know they know we are the most
regulated state in the nation with more
than
395 000 regulatory restrictions
it is a constant nightmare of inspectors
and permits and
fees in this state if you get to your
car 10 seconds
after the parking meter expires it's
already gone and you'll never see it
again
[Applause]
california has rules about every
nitpicky thing you can imagine
if you don't believe me try parking in
santa monica
or starting a business or getting your
solar power hooked
up
you can't fly a kite in a park in
beverly hills
or ride a bicycle or climb a tree but
for 30 years
nestle took water out of the san
bernardino national forest under a
permit that expired in 1988
and coca-cola is somehow allowed to take
water from municipal water supplies
stick it in bottles and sell it back to
the taxpayers who own the water to begin
with
395 000 regulations but somehow
that slipped through the cracks
a state that just loves to be up
everybody's ass
all the time water management might be a
better place to direct that instinct
i mean where is the heavy hand of
government when you need it
californians can live without nuts just
ask caitlyn jenner
but not water california to stop
thinking about how to get water on
almonds and start thinking about how to
get it on fires
it's basic logic that the more water we
don't waste by giving it to nestle
or using it to grow trail mix the more
we will have for the important stuff
china would probably figure it out how
to install a sprinkler system in the
fire prone areas and they'd do it in 10
days
i wish we lived still in an era where
the water
flowed like water
i like green lawns and big fountains and
while i don't play golf
i always like golf courses because they
keep douchey white people off the street
but
but global warming isn't in the future
it happened and now i want government to
deal with it
when it comes to regulations either go
big or go home
or i'm gonna find a new home because my
house is one
gender reveal party away from burning
down while i'm asleep
california i love you i've been here a
long time
i was a booster for you when it wasn't
fashionable
i don't want to go but i'm not going to
breathe ash
for the rest of my life you make me very
happy california
but i can be happy without you
you